this is a production of Cornell
University
so it's a real pleasure to be here at
Cornell and I'm glad that Alan arranged
it so that the snow cleared just before
my arrival okay so I'm going to be
talking about the nitrogen problem in
food production it's a it's a very
familiar problem and this is a very
familiar sight in most of our food
production in the in both the US and in
Europe heavy use of nitrogenous
fertilizers that promote crop growth and
really without that use of nitrogenous
fertilizers we couldn't support the
population that we currently support on
the planet and we certainly couldn't
support an expanding population going up
to 10 billion so it's very difficult to
see a society that that means itself off
this use of fertilizers i would say
we're very dependent on it's been
estimated that the natural nitrogen
cycle can support about 3 billion people
on the planet so you could imagine that
four billion people are currently
dependent on have abortion by 2050 will
about have about seven billion people
dependent on the harbor bosh process so
it's really hard to imagine how we get
away from this heavy use of light of
nitrogenous fertilizers now this is one
of the results of those nitrogenous
fertilizers this is a lake in China
heavily you throw heavy contamination
from nitrogen pollution causing these
algal blooms and certainly nitrogen
fertilizers are one of the major
agricultural pollutants that we get on
our planet and most of the nitrogen most
of the reactive nitrogen that is
polluting both our aquatic systems and
also our atmosphere is originating from
the use of nitrogenous fertilizers but
actually today I'm not really going to
talk too much about the environmental
degradation that we get from our
nitrogen fertilizers it's much more
focused on the inequality of the
availability of nitrogen fertilizers so
on this map i'm showing you the global
nitrogen consumption around the planet
and you can see that places and then
whether this i don't think these these
don't work do their pointers on the on a
screen like this but the the dark green
areas like here in the US
in Western Europe and China and India
heavy uses of nitrogen fertilizers and
as I said with all the consequence
environmental degradation but I think in
some ways a tragedy on this is when you
look at sub-saharan Africa it's almost a
blank on this slide very very limited
use of nitrogenous fertilizers in
African agriculture and that's because
most farmers in Africa in sub-saharan
Africa are small holder farmers less
than a hectare of land very little
financial resources available to them
and simply not the capability to
purchase a nitrogenous fertilizers of
financial capabilities available to
purchase a nitrogenous fertilizers and
as a result of that if we look at this
analysis that was published in Nature a
few years ago here they were asking what
is limiting mais productivity around the
planet so this is only looking at mayes
but if you look at you can go to this
paper and you can see also all the other
cereal crops wheat and rice but if it's
in green then it's already fifty percent
above the yield potential so that's out
of the analysis so it's only the regions
that are not achieving a yield potential
so well below the fifty percent yield
potential and the the areas that are not
achieving their yield potential they ask
is it an availability of nutrients or is
it the availability of water and I think
this is actually a very surprising
resource so blue means it's both
nutrients and water and red means it's
just nutrients so it's only parts of our
the arid areas of eastern africa where
if you you have to if you want to
increase your productivity you have to
irrigate and add fertilizers but most of
the maze growing areas in the world
particularly in sub-saharan Africa it's
really not what a limited limitation as
a restricting growth is the availability
of nutrients and those nutrients are
nitrogen and phosphorus the dominant
ingredients of fertilizers so if we are
going to increase productivity in these
areas of sub-saharan Africa in a
particular increased productivity for
smallholder farmers you have to tackle
this issue if you don't tackle this
issue then you cannot raise the yield
potential in those in those regions of
sub-saharan Africa fociless more where
for smallholder farmers are suffering
from the inability to produce enough
productivity now I would say there's
really two scenarios that by which we
can achieve this you could follow the
china model and in China they
essentially subsidize fertilizer
production by building fertilizer
factories producing lot vast amounts of
fertilizer that essentially brought the
cost of fertilizers down to the point
where smallholder farmers could afford
those fertilizers and and that's been a
very successful strategy in China the
consequences of it is massive excess use
of nitrogen fertilizers and the picture
I showed you is not surprisingly from
China where massive use of fertilizers
had led to huge scales of beautification
i would say that scenario is very
unlikely at least at the moment in
Africa most government in Africa cannot
afford to build large fact of the
fertilizer factories to support their
agricultural base and you know I would
say the countries that could afford it
like Nigeria they've got a lot of oil
wealth they're producing a lot of oil
wealth there seems to be a very little
desire to use that oil wealth to support
their agricultural base so it seems i
would say unlikely that we're going to
solve this issue of nitrogen
availability in sub-saharan africa by
just waiting for fertilizer prices to
come down to a point that small holder
farmers can afford them so that's why
the gates foundation is funding a
program that i had we call it
engineering the nitrogen symbiosis for
africa and this is essentially asking
can we utilize biological nitrogen
fixation so plants around the through
the evolution of plants they've really
many organism many times they've
struggled with the availability of
nitrogen the availability nitrogen is
not just a limitation in agriculture
it's also a limitation in some
environments of impotent of environments
in the natural world and to succeed in
those environments the plant has to find
a way to acquire nitrogen by other means
and one example of that of solving that
problem is shown here which is legumes
peas and beans that are able to interact
with nitrogen fixing bacteria resulting
in the formation of these
nitrogen fixing modules that are
essentially nitrogen factories on the
roots that can deliver the full need the
full nitrogen each of those plants now
the question is how can we use this
nitrogen fixing availability to address
the problems in nitrogen availability in
sub-saharan Africa certainly if we can
use biological nitrogen fixation it
provides a much more sustainable Avenue
for delivering nitrogen but that is a
hugely complex process to engineer what
I'm showing you here are all the nodules
on a pea root and moving that
transferring that capability the
complexity of producing a completely
novel organ into a serial root it's a
big challenge and I accepted it's a big
challenge so just to demonstrate the
opportunities in this area I've mocked
up this graph and it's a mock-up of a
graph but it is based on real data so on
the x-axis is looking at nitrogen
fertilizer application rates y-axis
we're looking at yields so it's a
familiar scientist you increase
fertilizer use you increase yields and
the world average for fertilizer uses
around 130 kilograms of nitrogen per
hectare here in the US you have somewhat
above that and in China we're actually
off the graph is around 220 kilograms of
nitrogen per hectare the in contrast
smallholder farmers are right at the
other extreme you smallholder farmers in
sub-saharan Africa using three to five
kilograms of nitrogen per hectare
extraordinarily low levels and that
includes not that's not just nitrogen
fertilizers that includes all their
manures that they have access to as well
so they're putting very very small
levels of nitrogen onto their fields and
as a result they're getting these
extremely low levels and I in this graph
I'm showing you the region that's
highlighted in blue I would say is a
region of greatest opportunity so
legumes actually fix nitrogen around 110
around 110 kilograms of nitrogen per
hectare so that's that's pretty well at
the top of this graph where were you
getting pretty well getting close to the
maximum potential yield so if I want to
replace
nitrogen fertilizers here in the US or
anywhere else in the developing world
agriculture I need to move in totality
the complexity of a nitrogen fixing p
nodular serial route but in in a context
of smallholder farmers there there at
the other extreme of this graph and in
fact relatively modest levels of
nitrogen fixation in smaller farming
systems can double or triple yields so
in that blue window of just around 25 to
50 kilograms of nitrogen if we can get
25 to 50 kilograms of fixed nitrogen
into the crops of smallholder farmers
then we're looking at doubling or
tripling the yield real great
opportunities there and in that regard
getting to that level of fixed nitrogen
i think is much more achievable so the
process of making a nodule is pretty
complex definitely we've got the it's a
bit dark on here but the on the left
you're seeing the prep mechanisms by
which the bacteria infect the legume
roots so they do so through root hair
curl root hairs that curl around the
bacteria they're attacking bacteria that
attach to the root air and they form
infection threads that grow down into
the root air and you can see the blue
staining as the bacteria inside the root
hair which will ultimately grow down all
the way in on the right you see a the
nodule has been initiated and the light
blue staining on the top is the
infection thread growing down into the
nodule and ultimately the bacteria
released into as infection droplets into
compartments within the cells where they
fix nitrogen so a lot of complexity
there and transferring all of that
complexity I would say is pretty
challenging but when you look at in the
leg room diversity of leggings you see
actually secret output the degree of
diversity in the complexity of these
nodule structures so on the right is a
nodule in medicago truncatula which i
would say is the pinnacle of this
evolutionary process but we see much
simpler modes of bacterial infections so
on the left here is a crack entry is a
it's a different mode it's not it's not
going through root hair
as much simpler mode of bacterial
infection that grows through where root
wearing where lateral roots break
through the epidermis and allow the
invasion of the bacteria and in the
middle our stem nodules on Oscar nominee
and those with you actually look at
these on a surface of a of an aspie
nominee shoot you would never say
they're nodules they're swellings on the
surface that have like hemoglobin
present in them they certainly do not
reflect the complexity that we see say
in medicago truncatula and I think while
the complexity that we see in say p or
medicago supports the high levels of
nitrogen fixation much of that
complexity is really about increasing
efficiency increasingly efficiency of
the nitrogen fixation process and if we
really talking about trying to get lower
levels of nitrogen fixation to say in a
25 450 kilograms of fixed nitrogen into
small other farming systems I think we
don't need all of that complexity we can
get away with some of the much more
simpler processes that we see say in ask
your nominee or incest Vanya and they
will deliver they won't deliver I don't
think we'll be able to replace nitrogen
fertilizers in totality with those kind
of systems but we can certainly deliver
very useful levels of fixed nitrogen to
to smallholder farmers in Africa and in
time I would say in time we will get to
the point I think it's just a matter I
truly believe we can move
nitrogen-fixing modules into cereals the
problem is just the complexity of the
process our deal with 20 years ago I you
I would have shocked you if I'd said we
can I can sequence your genome in a
couple of days time for a meaner one or
two thousand dollars and that's become
possible just in the last sort of 10 or
15 years technology is advancing its
advancing very quickly what we can't do
now we will be able to do in the future
so I hope that over time we can be
providing some level of fixed nitrogen
it's useful in a small holder farming
system and gradually getting to the
level of complexity that we see in Zeya
peor medicago nodule to really deliver
truly replacing nitrogenous fertilizers
also here in the devel
but in this shorter stage I think we can
actually probably deliver something much
more useful in the developing world than
perhaps what we might envision as in
replacing fertilizers here in the US
okay so in order to achieve that I
broken it down into I think there's four
main steps that we have to transfer into
cereals or four main processes that we
have to transfer into cereals to get
nitrogen-fixing modules into a cereal
crop one is to engineer the recognition
of the rhizobial bacteria that's the
very first step that happens when a
legume legging perceives the
nitrogen-fixing bacteria and then
initiates the processes associated with
accommodating those bacteria second
stages initiate the formation of a
nodule so transfer the nodule
organogenesis the capability to make
this new structure third process and
probably I think one of the most complex
is engineering the bacterial infection
process seats and lastly but not least
is engineering within the context of the
nodule in the pact with other bacteria
present the suitable environment for
nitrogen fixation so I would say that
those those four steps therefore quite
different steps for quite different
processes that we need to consider and
in the in the gates from the program
that we're initiating it's really at
this stage a proof of concept I'm
certainly not expecting to deliver
nitrogen-fixing cereals in two and a
half years which will be the end of the
first round of funding what we're
focusing on is a very first step
engineering rhizobial recognition into
cereals and putting aside at the moment
the second third and fourth steps
something to worry about for the future
rounds in the first round we need for
something that's achievable which is
engineering rhizobial recognition
cereals and we know that that rise over
your recognition sorry it's so dark but
we know that that rise over your
recognition is really the key step I
wonder if I can just pay increase the
brightness on my computer no I'm at the
max on my computer so it's not my
computer on me okay so the the processes
of recognition that are the way the
means by which a plan recognizes rise
over your bacteria every time a seed
germinate it has to find the rise over
your bacteria in the soil and it does so
through this chemical communication has
been known for a number
years the plant is releasing flavonoids
those are recognized by the rise over
your bacteria and that in turn initiates
the production of nod factors which are
diffusa belig NAL's coming from the rise
over your bacteria that are perceived by
the plant and nod factors are the
structure of nod factors as being very
well characterized it be known for
almost 20 years now it's a chiton
backbone with an ace I'll tail and then
we have a number of other decorations
around the molecules so this is a nod
factor saina rhizobium meliloti and
which is the symbiont of medicago
species and it's so theta Don the
reducing terminal sugar and it's
isolated on the non-reducing terminal
shin and those modifications are differ
between the different rhizobial species
and that to a degree defines the host
range and in fact when you look across
the diversity of rice obeah we see quite
a wide diversity in these signaling
molecules they always have the chitin
backbone they always have the ACL tail
but they have a variety of modifications
sulfation carbonylation puke oscillation
asset elation etc around this basic
structure and the other thing that
differs is a lengthened degree of
saturation of the SL tail and those
absolutely define the host range of the
different Rhizobium bacteria which
Rhizobium bacteria interacts with rich
legging species so in order to
understand how the plan was perceiving
those that non factor signaling molecule
we undertook a relative but a pretty
straightforward genetic screen where we
were just simply asking for mutants of
medicago that were incapable to activate
nodule formation in the response to
reserve your bacteria and this is
essentially the basis of the screen so
the dark spot on the root in the case a
place where the rhizobia were inoculated
on the root and you can see in a
wild-type line you get nodules forming
at that site and in a mutant in this
case n SP two mutant you knew the plant
is completely blind to the Rhizobium
bacteria and does is completely unable
to initiate nodule formation as a result
of that genetic screen we identified a
signal signal transduction pathway that
was responsible for perception of
rfactor and transmission of that signal
down to the suite of transcription
factors that are involved in
coordinating gene expression associated
with modulation now at the core of this
signaling pathway are oscillations in
calcium and I'll just just play you this
movie so this is a root SL of medicago
truncatula that we've microinjected with
a calcium responsive die and then what
you're seeing at the moment is just the
die re localizing around the cell but
when we treat this through with nod
factor you can see that the region of
the nucleus begins to oscillate its
calcium those oscillations are always in
the new predominantly in the nucleoplasm
but they're also occurring in the
nucleus OC a decider plasm we know that
the store of the calcium is in the new
is the endoplasmic reticulum but
particularly the region around the
nuclear envelope where the channels and
pumps associated with this response are
localized and that calcium oscillations
will continue for up to 24 hours while
over nod factor is present and it's
essentially transmitting the signal
saying that nod factor is recognized at
the plasma membrane and transmitting
that signal into the nucleus to activate
the ultimately activate the production
of the transcription factors in the
nucleus now the molecular value of that
pathway essentially we've got three main
complexes associated with this signaling
process firstly we got that receptor
like kinase errs that are involved in
perceiving the nod factor and there's a
suite of receptor like ionizers that
form a complex on the plasma membrane
that we are now known to actually bind a
nod factor molecule downstream of that
there are a suite of channels and pumps
on the nuclear membranes that are
associated with producing the calcium
oscillations and then downstream with
the calcium oscillations we have the
calcium decoding complexes this protein
calcic seek mkay cause calcium and
calmodulin dependent protein kinase and
it interacts with a transcription factor
and in conjunction with the suite of
other transcription factors or
ultimately coordinator gene expression
that's necessary to initiate this probe
the processes of nodulation and
bacterial infection so we know that
those calcium oscillations are central
not only as a signaling pathway
essential but the calcium oscillations
themselves are central and we know that
because the gain of fungus gain of
functions in the protein secam k which
is the decoding the calcium oscillations
so this is a protein that sits
immediately downstream of the calcium
oscillations it's a there's a kinase
with the capability to bind both calcium
on its own and then calcium in complex
with calmodulin almost certainly we know
is a protein that's decoding those
calcium oscillations we can create gain
of functions in that protein and when we
transform those gain of functions into
the legume roots we get spontaneous
induction of nodules in the absence of
rhizobial or nod factor so we know that
just switching on this protein alone is
sufficient to coordinate the whole
process of generating a nodule and the
whole developmental processes associated
with the formation of a nodule so that's
telling us that the calcium oscillations
alone are sufficient to court to
activate those those processes and once
you turn on this signaling pathway it
can coordinate all of the complexity of
development that's necessary to produce
this new structure the nodule now if we
look at the evolution of this process
and nodulation we most people think of
nodulation in legumes and that's very
familiar there is most legumes the
majority of legumes can nadja late but
nodulation is not actually restricted to
legumes that it's evolved multiple times
so are the red indicates as sort of
groups where nodulation has evolved and
there's multiple origins of the
evolution of nodulation but all
nodulation species are restricted to the
you to the ross and euro seeds so
there's a suggestion at a predisposition
event facilitated the emergence of the
evolution of nodulation but but the
importantly nodulation as a multiple
times and not only that nodulation has
emerged multiple times in the legume
species so there is not a single area as
far as we can tell either there's many
many thousands of plans that have lost
the capability to nodule eight or more
simply probably a few
so upwards of 10 12 origins of knowledge
of the emergence of nodulation in the
euro seeds so one question we had was is
this signaling process and the
capability to activate calcium
oscillations is that limited to the
legumes or is it more broadly and a
broadly occurring in the in also nod
modulating sorry nan legume modulating
species and these are the acting arise
all species like older trees that form
nodules not with rhizobial bacteria but
with Frankia a filamentous
nitrogen-fixing bacteria so for that we
wanted to look to add a number of
different species not only in the
legumes so all the work that being done
in the past on calcium and the signaling
pathway being restricted essentially to
medicago truncatula and lotus japonicus
which are the main model legumes and
very not no work had been done on the
mossen much more primitive legumes like
Cersei by kami christa which is the
nodule ating species or looking for
instance at cercis which is a non
modulating legume that will diverge
before the evolution of nodulation also
we wanted to ask in the the non the
nodule ating non legumes such as in the
cannabase either Paris Bonilla and is a
tree a tropical tree that can interact
with rice obeah involved nodules or for
instance older alnus glutinosa which is
a non legume that can interact with
Frankia bacteria so how common was this
capability to cordon to respond to
nitrogen fixing bacteria inactivate
calcium oscillations and for that we
chose this diversity of species and
looked at their capability to activate
calcium spiking and what we found
perhaps not surprisingly in all the
legumes that the capability to activate
nodulation is broad within the legumes
it doesn't occur as far as we can tell
in cercis which is a non modulating
legume importantly Paris Bonilla which
is the only non legume that can interact
with rhizobia is also activating calcium
oscillations in response to its
rhizobial sin by on and similarly older
species which interact not with rhizobia
whether the Frank here and we know that
these Frankia bacteria not
using nod factor molecules are producing
a completely different signaling
molecule they are also activating
calcium oscillations so if it's telling
us that even though nodulation evolved
multiple times as far as we can tell as
far as we've looked in all the times
where nodulation evolved it recruited
this signaling pathway and utilize the
same signaling mechanisms to activate
the processes so it's clear that if we
want to transfer this capability into
cereals this signaling pathway is
central to that process because it's
been central to every case where
nodulation has evolved I can't say every
case because there's some to curb it's
where we haven't been able to look at
yet but all the cases that we've been
able to look at the capability to
perceive them that Rhizobium bacteria
and activate the symbiosis signaling
pathway is a common feature and so
clearly we need to be able to transfer
this signaling capability into cereals
if we're going to be elder transfer
nitrogen-fixing modulation so if so so I
would say I have to recapitulate the
signaling pathway in cereals now that is
a daunting challenge especially if you
think of the complexity of activating an
oscillatory calcium behavior in your
nucleus I would not like to be able to
have to reengineer that thankfully I
don't have to do that and the reason is
because actually the signaling pathway
that we are genetically dissected in
medicago was actually not really a
nodulation signaling pathway it's
actually a micro riesel signaling
pathway at the core of this signaling
Pat the cause of signaling pathway is
what we call the comment symbiosis
signaling pathway it's Julie required
not only for the conch of the perception
of rice over your bacteria but it's also
required for recognition of arbuscular
mycorrhizal fungi now the capability to
perceive arbuscular mycorrhizal fungi
goes lot goes way back and it sorry I'm
a little bit ahead of myself so if we
look at the molecular viewpoint the
common signaling components are all
shaded in blue here are the components
that we know are common to the two
nodulation and micro izel signaling and
the red components
the unique components so so that the
receptor complexes it's only the nod
factor receptors that are specific to
the rhizobial recognition there is a
co-receptor called Samar kayla's already
Julie required for nodulation and
rhizobial recognition all of the
components that are required for the
generation of calcium oscillations and
the components that are required for the
perception of calcium oscillations are
we do lyric wired for mycorrhizae and
nodulation and only really when we start
to get to the transcription factors
where we get the specificity in this
process where the transcription factors
have specific functions in nodulation
and do not appear to be predominantly
involved in the micro izalith
sophistication so the micro izel
association has many parallels to
nodulation the signaling processes
within a similar regard to nodulation
the perception of rhizobial bacteria the
plant is resumed releasing signaling
molecules in this case stryger lactones
and they activate the production of
diffusible signaling molecules coming
from the micros or fungi recall make
factors very similar parallels to how
rhizobial bacteria are perceived and
those parallels go even greater but if
we look at how this these processes are
evolved well modulation emerged around
60 million years ago and was restricted
to a number of groups of plants in the
euro seeds our vascular micro zation is
much more ancient it dates back at least
450 million years ago right to the root
of the plant kingdom so all plans this
is what the blue is indicating all plans
at least at one time had the capability
to form arbuscular mycorrhizal fungi and
we know that at least about 80% of
higher plans can form the arbuscular
mycorrhizal symbiosis the plans that
can't like a rabid opsys have lost that
capability but their ancestors they've
created their ancestors certainly had
that capability so importantly all the
monocots that are the targets for our
engineering process have the capability
to form the arbuscular mycorrhizal
association and therefore we would
predict have the symbiosis signaling
pathway so therefore this signaling
pathway should in theory be in
cereal crops and I don't actually have
to re-engineer all of that complexity of
producing and decoding calcium
oscillations I simply have to follow the
evolutionary trajectory that's happened
in legumes that essentially is converted
what is a monofunctional signaling
pathway into a bifunctional signaling
pathway where we've got one signaling
pathway involved in the recognition of
my cries of fun day and rhizobia whereas
in cereals it's only the recognition of
microwaves or fungi where this pathway
is functioning okay so work from wouter
pesckow skis lab has shown that this
signaling pathway is indeed present in
cereals and that's shown here with
genetics so on the top is a wild-type
rice route that's been colonized by
micro eyes or fungi and all the dark
blue staining is a fungus it gets very
heavily the roots get very heavily
colonized by the fungus and if we make
mutations in any component for the
common symbiosis signaling pathway and
rice then the fungus can form the
initial infection structures on the
surface but is unable to colonize the
root so and that's exactly the same
phenotypes that we see in legumes so we
can recapitulate the mutant phenotypes
in cereals that we see in legumes
indicating that this signaling pathway
is certainly present not only present
but it's fulfilling equivalent role in
the recognition of my cries or fungi but
more than that we can actually do the
parallels with the signaling pathway Go
Go more significant than that because we
can take the genes from rice and trans
complement them in a med into the
medicago mutants and on the bottom panel
here is a medicago mutant of secam k so
calcium decoder that mutant cannot
normally form nodules that when we
transform it with seek mkay from rice
then it complements not only for micro
zation but it also complements for
nodulation indicating that this
signaling pathway in the evolution of
this signaling pathway there's nothing
that's changed in the core processes of
the signaling pathway that has allowed
this signaling pathway to be bi
functional the common symbiosis
signaling pathway is there and
functional as functional in cereals as
it is in legumes so I would argue then
that cereals have the innate but as yet
unrecognized capability to
perceive and respond to rhizobial
bacteria and engineering that process is
actually because of these evolutionary
history is much simpler than perhaps we
would have thought a decade ago and
therefore for the engineering components
of the hour our grand we're really
focusing just on the receptor complexes
what we really need to do is to get the
receptor complex as present and
functional and then the transcription
factors compo transcription factor
complexes present and functional to
transfer the capability for this this
signaling pathway to be bi functional it
doesn't tell us we're going to make a
nodule I accept there's a long arrow
going to not to generating the
complexity of a nitrogen fixing nodule
but as I said at the moment I parked all
that complexity at the moment all we're
trying to do is transfer recognition of
rhizobia as a first step towards
engineering nitrogen-fixing series okay
so if we really want to understand this
to the the signaling pathway in cereals
in fact what we need to do is to
understand this context shown here where
the this is a plant root in a so clean
close proximity to my cries or fungi and
it's at this early stage as where the
fungus is growing down towards the route
where this signaling pathway is
functioning at least the first stage of
where the signaling pathways functioning
where de fusible signaling molecules
produced by the from the mike rizzo
fungus are being recognized by the root
activating that symbiosis signaling and
then promoting the the processes that
are necessary to accommodate the micro
eyes or fungi and the first one of the
first steps that we've taken in the
gates funded program is to understand
what cereals are actually recognizing
from mycorrhizal fungi to activate
that's their signaling pathway so in the
last few years it was showing the micro
riesel fungi produce lipo keto
oligosaccharides that are structurally
very similar to rhizobial nod factors so
it's very clear that the parallels going
of signaling of those signaling
processes are going continuously all the
way from a signaling molecule through to
the signaling pathways and probably all
the way through to the colonization of
the route by the by the rise of your
bacteria so micro riesel fungi producing
like a key to all I saccharides
structurally very similar to rhizobial
nod factors and it was proposed that
those were the mick factors that were
being recognized by the plant but now in
the second group also from toulouse was
arguing as an alternative hypothesis
which was that my guys'll fungi produce
also much simpler kaitou
oligosaccharides are completely
undecorated so no a telltale none of the
sulfation elicit elation that you see in
some of the l cos and that it was
actually those short chain i tol oka
saccharides that were the signaling
molecules those were the things that are
activating the symbiosis signaling
pathway implants so we took both of
these kind of classes of signaling
molecules and asked what water cereals
recognizing and what is activating the
symbiosis signaling pathway so for that
we generated rice lines that had calcium
reporters the chameleon which allows us
to measure calcium and tested an array
of different signaling molecules
different lcos both at the top is the
mica riesel produced lcos and then we're
testing lcos from broad-spectrum
rhizobia that produce a whole spectrum
of different lco signaling molecules and
you can see that we really do not see
any responses to the lco signaling
molecules that we do see responses to
the shuttle ish the chitin
oligosaccharide and that's just showing
here just in graph form where we're
looking at the percentage of cells that
can activate calcium oscillations and
you can see really no response
whatsoever to the lco but very good
responses to the cato oligosaccharides i
want to highlight here that we're
looking at very high concentrations of
these signaling molecules 10 to the
negative 5 molar that's very high
concentration so we read we chose those
concentrations simply so that if we got
a negative result we can be very very
confident that that plant is not
responding to those LCOS so if we
compare on the top here or two different
species of legumes medicago and lotus
that are in showing their responses to L
cos and cos and the bottom are two non
leggings tomato and rice and really the
main differences that we see between
legumes and non legumes is a capability
to respond to lco signaling molecules so
both non legumes and legumes can respond
to kite oligosaccharides and activate
the symbiosis signaling pathway but the
ability to perceive
Co seems to be an innovation that's
happened in in the legumes and probably
strongly associated with a capability to
respond to rise over your bacteria so I
would argue that this innovation has
happened in legumes is clearly important
for the Cape for the for the for the
capability to activate nitrogen-fixing
nodulation and something that we really
need to be able to transfer into non
legumes to allow recognition of
rhizobial bacteria so in our project we
have as I said to two main focuses
firstly the engineering the perception
of the nod factor which is the
transferring the receptors from legumes
into cereals to allow nod factor
recognition and in the second half we're
using the gain of functions I showed you
we have gained of functions in our seek
MK there's also gain of functions in its
interacting partners Cyclops those gain
of functions can coordinate the whole
processes of modulation in legumes so
using those gain of functions in
combination with the transcription
factors to activate reporters and is
very modest my expectations at this
stage are very very modest can we
transfer nod factor activation of
calcium spiking into cereals and can
using the gain of functions in C cam k
in combination with the transcription
factors activate reporters simply leg
Yuma porters that are reporters
modulation specific reporters simply is
a very simple question can we
recapitulate the signaling capability in
cereals and it's important I think at
this stage that we keep our expectations
modest I don't expect to be able to
transfer this this process and get a
nodule but I do keep a relatively open
mind about what will happen if we
transfer the capability for cereals to
recognize rhizobial bacteria and
importantly activate the symbiosis
signaling pathway that coordinates the
processes that are necessary for a
mutualistic symbiosis with a with a
microorganism it might be that it will
facilitate improved colonization of
cereal roots by rhizobial bacteria but I
doubt we'll get nodules now
unfortunately it's just the nature of
having to go and give seminars I wish I
could wait a couple of years and give
this seminar because it's too early to
say what the results are we're doing a
lot of
at the moment we've got an awful lot of
transgenic lines coming from barley we
have some promising preliminary results
but it's just too early to really say
definitively whether this approach has
been successful so I just wanted to
highlight some of the challenges that we
have in engine in this engineering
process this is really one of the most
complex engineering processes that there
isn't in the in the public sector it's
certainly comparable to transferring fee
for photosynthesis which is another of
the gate funded programs so what are the
challenges that we face in engineering
something of this level of complexity so
so firstly I just want to reiterate with
we're working on their different
complexes so one of the complexes is the
receptors and I just want to highlight
again that the co-receptors MRK which we
know is involved in transmitting the
signal to activation of the nuclear
calcium oscillation that co-receptor is
already present in cereals it's already
there because it's a micro izel specific
component presumably as a co-receptor
with mick factor receptors which are
come fortunately we currently still
don't know what they are but all we
really need to do is to get the nod
factor receptors in a stable form we
presume they'll form a complex with that
co-receptor and therefore they should
activate the nuclear calcium
oscillations and the other signaling
processes that we need to transfer not
with the gain-of-function we can just
use the gain of functions to all to
activate the pathway cereals already
have seek MK but we we can use the gain
of functions as a way to switch on the
pathway and the important thing is
whether we can get these different
transcription factor complexes to
activate their appropriate promoters in
serial routes ok so one of the biggest
challenges in transferring those
processes I would say is what promoters
you use so do we just use 35s we can't
use we've got many genes to transfer we
can't really just keep using the same
promoter again and again we need
multiple promoters to drive the
different proteins and exactly when we
look at this we've got quite a few
proteins to get stabili present in a
serial route what level of expression of
say secam cave relative to the
transcription factor isn't necessary
should we just put them all on
constitutive promoters and pray it's a
it's a difficult thing and especially
and you don't know what the algorithm if
we get a negative result is that because
the promoters we're not going to write
level of expression or is it because
there's assumptions in our processor
yeah that was actually missing
components that we don't know about in
the legging system so it's very
important particularly when you're
setting up a large serial transformation
process that if you get a negative
result that that negative result can be
informative you have at least trying
that clearly we feel like we have to
stack our cards as much as possible to
get a positive outcome and we can
overcome any technological difficulties
so I would say this is just looking at
the expression of secam k its wrist no
wrist expression is normally restricted
to epidermal cells but then when you get
rhizobial colonization and the arrow
indicates the point where rice over your
colonizing the root there you can see
that secam k is expressed in a region of
the root around that rise over your
colonization so how do we recapitulate
that because cereals they've never seen
rise over here before they don't have a
the transcription factors that
coordinate this expression pattern when
we're moving if you want to just change
root development obviously you just use
a root promoter but here we're
transferring a new capability into
cereals as sears capability than ever
had before so there aren't any cereal
promoters that will do that for us so
what promoters should we use and I think
that this is one of our biggest
challenges at this stage and you know we
can do something like this and this is a
whole panel of different promoters we've
hooked up to Gus and then expressed in
roots Anna perhaps what should I just
use the strongest expresses is that the
right thing to do I don't know what
level of expression should a
transcription factor be to give us a
relative to other transcription factors
so I find personally find this sort of
analysis really uninformative it's how
we started this process it's like okay
we just need to make a lot of promoter
dust recorders put them into serial
roots and the ones that are blue we're
the ones we're going to use yeah it's
not that I find that very dissatisfying
and not particularly informative we've
done it but all we have is some roots
that are blue and some roof that aren't
so I would say this is probably the most
informative analysis we can get on
telling us which promoters
we use and here we've text amost lee
serial promoters we've used a variety of
different serial promoters constitutive
promoters route specific promoters and
then promoters that dried serial
promoters that drive SE secam k or
Cyclops so they should be sital ready
symbiotically relevant promoters and
what we've done is we've driven the
cecum k protein but with these promoters
and transform those into the sea camp a
mutant and ask how well we can
complement a medicago seek MK mutant
using serial promoters and right here is
the control because that's the medicago
gene driven by its native promoter so
that's a level of complementation that
we can get just from the native promoter
and you can see there's actually quite a
few serial promoters that do just as
well if not better than a native
promoter and those are pointers were
actually taken from serials which
transform them into a leg you and they
are activating the appropriate
expression of seek MK so I would say
that that's as good as we can get we now
also recapitulating this bitran using
those same promoters to test
complementation of the rice mutants
formica ization so at least it tells us
that those promoters work in a
symbiotically relevant context and I'm
expressing these genes and I think we're
currently doing this for all of the
genes that we're engineering testing you
finding out which promoters are best for
which genes at least in a legume context
which will then I think at least stack
our cards we can't guarantee we're going
to get exactly the same expression when
we go back into a cereal but at least
we're starting with cereal promoters and
if they work in a leguminous symbiotic
context I'm optimistic that they'll work
in a cereal in a symbiotic context but I
think we're still shooting in the dark a
little bit and I don't think that this
is really I think we're still in a
somewhat in perfect scenario so the in
an engine from an engineering
perspective this is a very familiar
cycle from an engineering perspective if
you want to design a jet engine you go
through this process of design build
test
and then use the test to inform the next
design and then build and always
improving and that's how we get to these
perfect jet engines that can't rise
across the Atlantic and this is a sort
of process in this sort of essentially
it's a synthetic biology approach we
have to move something new from the farm
legumes into cereals and create a new
functionality and cereals that cereals
do not yet have so are they on the
left-hand end design end essentially if
we in an engineering perspective you
move through this cycle many times
before you release a jet engine let you
sell to Boeing and I think we have to do
exactly the same I can't just go through
the cycle once and voila hour I'm going
to have a nitrogen fixing cereal it's
not how it's going to work I need to
move through this process many times we
might in this first round of
transformations get nothing it might all
be negative results in which case we
have to scratch our heads and say okay
what does that tell us go back redesign
rebuild retest so the left hand side
which sort of the design and build side
we've really tackled that very well we
got sorry we've got Golden Gate cloning
which is a modular mode of cloning
allows you you synthesize the modules
you stick stitch them together to make
gene modules those in cells became
modules that you can stitch together
into complex binary vectors and using
Golden Gate cloning we can produce
hundreds of constructs within a week it
trivialized the production of constructs
so we can make many constructs and this
modularity is actually very important
because we're testing different
promoters with different genes even
while we're finding when we do that same
promoter testing we do the same we
terminators we find some terminators
work and some terminators don't work for
complementation so you really need to
mix and match promoters open reading
frames and terminators and then mix and
match the genes that go into your binary
vectors in order to test as many
iterations and many possibilities as you
can in this engineering strategy so the
Golden Gate modularity has really
trivialized the production of the
constructs but getting those constructs
into serials is a huge headache so we
have maximized our through
into cereals and we're putting 150
constructs into cereals this year and
will do the same again next year another
150 constructs that's actually pretty
good in a public sector in a couple of
years getting 300 constructs into
cereals but when you look at what's
being done in synthetic biology in
bacteria so I take an example Chris Foy
just down the road at MIT he's mood
tonight Raja neighs from nitrogen-fixing
bacteria into non nitrogen-fixing
bacteria and to do so he moved all the
regulatory elements he created his own
regulatory circuit and then he
transformed that into into mountain on
nitrogen fixing bacteria and looked for
the capability to transfer to initiate
nitrogen fixation to optimize to get to
a level where he's getting back to the
original levels of nitrogen fixation
that the starting but starting bacteria
had he had to test 80,000 constructs and
so to do that he roboticized the whole
process he he made liquid handling
robots that make the constructs liquid
handling mobile apps that do the
transformation liquid angling mo dots
that do the measurements of the
nitrogenase there's no point when any
person is actually doing any of that the
person is the one pay the poison is
doing it is feeding it into a computer
that is designing all the constructs or
designing the principles that then the
computer designed the constructs 80,000
constructs and I'm doing something much
more complex than moving nitrogenase on
one bacteria to another I think moving
nitrogen fixation from leggings for
cereals is pretty damn complex so i am
not tackling this at anything close to
the level of complexity that we
currently need to do and the ability to
move through this cycle i can do it at
150 constructs a year or that's pretty
painful going so i think that one of the
big problems for us in dealing with this
complexity is a synthetic biology plant
synthetic biology is just not good
enough yet we don't yet have the tools
and one of the biggest bottle necks for
us is transformation so one area that I
think can be useful for us and we're is
an area we're now putting into place I
said Mike riesel the mycorrhizal
symbiosis is ubiquitous in the pine
kingdom
and that means even mosses and
liverworts do the micros or symbiosis so
this guy which is a liver word McCann
TIA it's a organism that's haploids very
simple genetics you can transform it
just by grinding it up in the two in a
tube putting it in a liquid with
agrobacterium when you plated out two
weeks later you have a fully functional
liverwort so this is sort of as close as
I think we're ever going to get implants
at synthetic biology and the sort of
capability where we can start to
roboticize the processes and get
probably not 80,000 constructs but at
least in the thousands of constructs
that we can test in a reasonable amount
of time to actually test the complexity
problem is my county doesn't have roots
so the likelihood that I'm ever going to
get a nitrogen fixing knowledgeable on
to make hands here is very low but it
does have the symbiosis signaling
pathway so at least such a framework for
engineering symbiosis signaling I think
mccann tier is a very good framework at
least for this first stage and so we're
now in the process of putting the
Kantian as a complement to the work that
we do in serials to really start to make
this throughput much greater into to
tackle it I think at the level that we
really need to do but I think just just
ending here on it on I just want to
reiterate that we're really just
tackling the first stages here and while
the this evolutionary trajectory and the
evolutionary trajectory makes the first
stage as much simpler it actually
probably is also very clear that
bacterial infection is also reusing the
same processes that Michael Riedel fungi
use so I think it's very clear that the
whole process of nitrogen fixation has a
surface piggybacked on the mycorrhizal
symbiosis and that evolutionary
trajectory means that i think is much
simpler for us to engineer nitrogen
fixation into cereals because we're not
having to really re-engineer anything
new in cereals we have served the
existing biology that's present there
even so the complexity of the process is
such that I think we need much better
plan synthetic biology tools and in some
ways I think I have to build the bridge
in plan synthetic biology before we can
truly
tackle this and that's for me that's the
what the next round of gates funding is
going to be about not just pushing into
these other four areas but also putting
in place of synthetic biology tools that
allow us to really tackle something of
this complexity okay I just like to
acknowledge the people involved in the
word this is an international program of
research my collaborators Jean Denarius
group in Toulouse where I've been
working on the L cos and CEOs and
helping us to understand what what
signaling molecules cereals recognize
the joists van Eck who's out vti here in
court hearing Ithaca is helping us with
some of the transformation Tom Brundle
is also helping us with a maze and the
cereal Mason's terrier work and then
both myself and yen stagger the real
engineering labs were pushing the
production of the receptors and the the
downstream calcium decoding complex and
these are just the members of my own
group who are part of the answer program
and I would also just like before I
finish just really acknowledge the gates
foundation because nobody else has been
willing to take the risk it's a
high-risk high-reward project there's no
way I'm going to be delivering
nitrogen-fixing serials anytime soon
Gates Foundation absolutely recognize us
a long-term program and are willing to
put the funds up in the beginning and I
think a lot of people will say it's not
possible it's too complex you can't
possibly do it and my answer is if you
don't start now you certainly will never
achieve it if you start now maybe
there's a chance of achieving it I
really acknowledge the gates foundation
for taking thank
yes at your big question yes so the
question is penny during a different way
other simpler ways like and for instance
put a nitrogen fixing plastic create an
item using plastered and the obvious
thing is to do nitrogenous from bacteria
into a plastic where it's functioning
already as a biologically stations in a
plant cell and there is actually a
second gate from the program let's run
by Luis coolio in Madrid doing exactly
that so they're trying to move
nitrogenase actually to the line of
andreea the recently doing your
mitochondria is it a low-oxygen
environment already because it
respiration means that oxygen is being
utilized it's also it has a lot of
conductive powers wearing my charger
place and if the verses that are just
trying to get back into their money for
the yeast mitochondria as a stepping
stone to class now there is a neither
sense of perception of that simple I
will argue with that possession at a
simpler nitrogenated of hugely complex
answer most complex enzyme has the
unique cofactors is or four centers and
living / factors that you need to
control them so you're not just going to
get the components of nitrogenase there
peace so it's not straightforward just
to read my party's over I argue that I
had the photos I know it was like he's
beautiful they fix all their attitudes
myself not on the record but many
different species of plants that evolved
this capability and what you completely
implanted parking birthplaces so I'll
argue that I have the advantage I have a
perfectly and so matter I know it works
and I know if I transferred after series
it works it transferring nitrogenase is
a viable approach that I wouldn't say
it's simpler or less obvious it's just
as much risk but i think is illegitimate
the night Republican father I think it's
a totally legitimate to have more
multiple avenues to try to sell yes oh
so that's what this very important
question and I was sorry that I have a
big question so the question is on
specificity so we have a vine optional
signaling pathway yet specific a course
and I actually showed you that the gain
of function in c can k alone and
activates ecology and yet we my crazy
mind i come along the activex a protein
recounting oscillations in the donated
module so clearly specificity is there
making contact that the linking must
nervous is recognizing loss factor even
better this activation see so we were
sailing be working specificity for years
and i really thought it's encoded in the
structure of the oscillations because we
saw initially with the my cries of
contract we saw what look like different
types of insulations but actually now
the working of signaling molecules it
service they're exactly the same the
structurally oscillations is identical
between our vaca signals and the signals
coming from Mike Rice punch even so we
do see different gene expression that is
too
and that are dependent on the presence
in my as a secret way so it's clear that
is not its specificity is not because as
other signaling molecules be produced by
them like all those Latin to be a my
argument it's still that the signals
themselves having Gretchen eyes and
specificities of the recognition of
those signals so I would say there's
probably some parallels signaling just
go back way okay I would say that it was
probably not much more than that but
there might very well be parallel
sequined he noticed that grass proteins
which anyone has beaten man what those
are grass coatings of no importance we
actually don't know how it activated and
possibly one possibilities that is
parallel sinkage addressable status
straight affairs grass protein and the
combination of the activation of those
versions of combinations symbiosis even
halfway that means that running and
automation one context or but net leases
yes yes that's a very legitimate
question so in western is Emily haven't
just get by Zoe's and leading
molecule that my class apart they're
producing it that is actually part of
our strategy may have a day that's one
of the main reasons we're working out
exactly what cereals are recognizing
because then I could see to recognizing
just a simple version of an artifact I'm
a little wary to say it's just title X a
crisis clear the title exact reticle
activating sibling pathway but we still
have to use quite high concentrations of
those molecule to get a response much
higher most racism use dark matter I'm
currently testing we have some evidence
that it might be decorated high
tolerance at work not decorated with the
base our tail has decorated with sort of
asian population or detect some of the
other decorations at the co-op so
evidence it might give that greater
payoff of psychoactive the current
testing so that very much part of a
reasonable understanding exactly what it
is a serious recognized my Chrysler fun
time because a much simpler strategy
would be to mentally advisory just to
make a lot of that signal and there was
you move the be able to colonize anybody
hello you gotta get
this might take you and the second
question is do you envision that you
would have to call inoculated with human
species or do you think the engineer
serials could make use of natural yeah
favorite questions I I so the first
question ever say I hate that first
question getting all the time now is
when we going to get back a piece of
cereal and has an incredibly difficult
question to answer because if we really
moving into them no we don't quite know
how much of the factors that
presentation iceberg cereals and exactly
when we can do that so it's very
difficult to judge but but my point for
highlighting in the beginning I think
there's opportunities in in the along
the process that perhaps we can deliver
useful that is a fixed nitrogen that
would be hugely beneficial to small
farmers well before we kind of place in
fertilizers here well so I want to
mystic that we can be there at least you
did mine career I hope it's not fine
when waiting for many future generations
to solve this problem but I'm optimistic
that we can at least we delivering some
level of useful fixed nitrogen within
the next 50 years whether that's in the
context of having a fully functional p
nodular Sira group I think that that's
optimistic to say too many points but i
also would say technologies moving very
quickly and as betty clean synthetic
biologist and very violent some place
that I think
feasible so it can be having recently
open mind how long this is gonna take
and the second question is would be not
going I guess with an inoculum can't we
just get them to use the native right so
I will be very hard to imagine how a
good engineer for the days of ice over
your presence here and at least at this
stage I think in fact to know what
signaling molecule reproduce by the rise
earlier probably and the first instance
we would probably require and said
because at least think you've got
control over the flat side of bacteria
so they know the back tears run the
juice of the signal that you engineer
the fantasies I don't think Pablo so the
question is that the question is do we
have is there something intrinsic
serious awesome reality of the process
of wines here if not anticipate those I
think it's not a medium of the evolution
cereals just diverged well before
modulation emerged in a simplest reason
say why serious i'm advocating it were
did overly and in thinking that in
agriculture created a situation where
plan part 2 it is highly ranked and as a
animal system when we strip everything
all about interior of the soil and then
come back next year my muse these and
expect to get hyperactivity there's
there's no system natural
like that so we've created a system
that's hugely dependent on always
animatic nutrients a natural system has
a much more natural beauty cycle so in
very many environments fixing nitrogen
is not the be-all and end-all is not
competitive advantage so in fact when
you look at that use where they succeed
are tend to be in places where Naidu is
limited so short grass mats acidic soils
tropical soils are the very low
nutrients so i think i would say that in
the natural world nitrogen in some
context is is the major factor but in
many contexts just not so so you don't
necessarily have to solve our problem
and there are costs of making their many
different examples where do through it
classif and different ways of solving
this problem and I think for serial
probably international context it's not
the viola handle that serious can't grow
in areas where light engines on so i
mean i would say nonetheless something
in trees it's a series of softened it's
just that it just didn't happen
but we created a false online where
nitrogen is the key I think about them
women anything I have charged our
contacts phone because it's probably the
most recently evolved not example of
conservation and it's also probably most
simple is crack entering infection the
bacterial infection thread they don't
get released into a steady affection for
us to fix nitrogen cycling freshman
stress though it's as far as i can tell
you it's also very clearly a modified
much which is not complex module so i
will save us going to try to pitch pitch
late anything in the house phone genetic
dissection of modulation pass pending
photography the thing is it's just not
interesting so i think i have to work
with a system by which i can judge an
enemy myself is process that is the
model rankings there is yet to be an
atomizer species must be developed
pregnant but i am i SPECT versus was
already some nary a mark upon his people
trying to develop a model i think i am
too far away and i can't wait for that
to stop we've got enough information
like that
and it's clear these particular taxpayer
because it's the same signaling pathway
I think you pretty well say yes so
that's a very good question and I'm
saying that that that bad badtz that
aggression is how is there is a real
plenty when you get nitrile do some
serious and that is a really easy answer
to organize their right impossible I
heard if you look at a field of days in
Africa is yellow most of the time so
there no synthetic capacities being
limited by the availability of nutrients
so I think that there are so far down
the levels of nitrogen that are
available that there's no way even if
you're having to fix your our nitrogen
you are pushing productivity oxy
difficult because you're starting on
social earth days that argument becomes
important when you're starting to today
and we totally replace nitrogen
fertilizers we biological nitrogen
fixation and in that regard yes I'm sure
there is in your penalty but we can't
leave without the environmental
sustainability and the economics
the current model where we're using
faster man fertilizers and the average
Barbara spin is earning the UK at forty
percent we production costs money the
purchase an application of action
fertilizers so I allow you to take
twenty percent yield still at not be
viable hat levels as they so yes there
is in your town that was I suspect there
will be anything that would probably not
going to get a teal teal team to get
upwards of 70 80 kilograms of nitrogen
sort of more modest that cleverly so the
situation we find request items oh it's
wonderful that the email resettling also
to my sin receta like I this isn't all
over my hands you know to other there's
a few other by sem proteins i have just
my son I've got a monster so we're
getting generation to myself I'm
guessing now remember well it took a
while to get unfortunately me Mackenzie
employed all purposes the model has been
developed is a non micronized speech
it's a songs on trend that we've
developed a model plants in so much to
find one on one with one of the few
twenty percent month ago for bike riders
advice especially Nia so the we had to
develop a new my cries mercantil model
which we've chosen
so now translation work is going either
Christa work in order to that stuff but
that's in my place will pair we have is
also in such persons of testing
compensation I'm guessing is going to be
the same we ordered over the same
pathway in from Vista one child
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu